buongiorno io di cosa vi parlerò vi
parlerò della più brutta malattia che
c'è in italia che è il fatalismo
protestatario non sapete cos'è il
fatalismo protestatario è quella
malattia quel virus che che che noi la
nostra popolazione alberga si tiene
dentro e che praticamente ci fa dire
vabbè ma vabbè non si può fare niente
vabbè non si può cambiare in questo
paese non c'è niente da fare
vabbè potrai inventarmi un nuovo virus
il virus va bene e vi parlerò di come se
vogliamo sconfiggere questo virus
dobbiamo credere nel cambiamento e
soprattutto dobbiamo avere coraggio di
investire nel cambiamento e dobbiamo
avere la voglia di metterci in gioco noi
stessi io vi parlerò della mia
esperienza vi racconterò una storia vera
una testimonianza che però vuole essere
una speranza per tutti i ragazzi e
ragazze soprattutto che si occupano di
ricerca che che vogliono diciamo
cambiare questo paese e che vogliono
mettersi in gioco per un'italia migliore
soprattutto se lo fanno da un ente
pubblico perché io lavoro in un ente
pubblico sono 25 anni che lavoro in un
ente pubblico del servizio sanitario
nazionale e sono orgogliosa di farlo e
voglio di mostrarvi che anche nel
servizio pubblico si possono fare delle
cose straordinarie
allora il primo dogma di cui vi parlerò
perché voglio infrangere dei dog ma
voglio voglio mostrarvi che che è
possibile infrangerli e che in italia
non si può fare ricerca di eccellenza
allora questo non è vero ve lo dico io
ma lo sapete avete anche qui in trentino
tanti più entry eccellenza quello però
che è vero è che ci vogliono mille
braccia
cioè non è che poi tanto facile fare
ricerca ci vogliono mille braccia
bisogna combattere la burocrazia bisogna
combattere
l'ingessatura della rigidità mentale dei
nostri amministratori e bisogna lavorare
sodo lavorare tantissimo ma soprattutto
bisogna saper cavalcare le tigri perché
le tigri passano e se avete la
conoscenza l'impegno la consapevolezza
che quella è una tigre che va cavalcata
voi non dovete spaventarvi e dovete
cavalcare la tigre perché le tigri
rappresentano delle grandissime
opportunità per far emergere il nostro
talento le nostre capacità
allora io sono un veterinario sono
studiato veterinaria sapete perché
perché volevo andare via di casa
io sono di roma e l'unica facoltà
scientifica che non c'era roma era
veterinaria e quindi io ho preso o
convinto i miei genitori che che mi
piacevano tantissimo gli animali che
peraltro anche vero insomma mi piacciono
gli animali però come a tutti ecco e noi
vogliamo bene agli animali abbiamo
sentito prima però sapevo che non avrei
mai esercitato anche perché se uno non è
portata o meglio che non esercita e
quindi sono andato a studiare
veterinaria e mi son contro la fan
contro tutti
e poi non sono più tornato a casa e poi
la vita ti porta dove ti porta a me mi
ha portato a studiare i virus emergenti
sono quei virus che dal serbatoio
animale si si spostano all'essere umano
e possono provocare diciamo delle
catastrofi come per esempio il virus
dell hiv perché anche se noi pensiamo di
essere diversi dagli animali c'è un polo
siamo però dal punto di vista di un
virus noi non è che siamo tanto diversi
perché virus ricerca i recettori i
recettori i nostri sull'apparato
respiratorio sono uguali ai recettori di
un maiale animale a caso e quindi
insomma questi virus è abbastanza
agevolmente fanno il salto di specie e
possono quando entrano in una
popolazione nuova possono veramente
creare dei disastri allora io sono
si sente che non sono veneta e sono sono
romana è però sono quasi 16 anni che
vivo in veneta mia figlia che qui parla
veneto però perché è nata qui è nata in
veneto e e sono arrivata all istituto
zooprofilatico di cui c'è una sezione
anche a trento che lavora molto bene nel
1998 era un laboratorio piccolo aveva
eravamo sei sette persone e facevamo
diagnostica a livello locale sulle
malattie del bene degli animali del
veneto e non incidevano per niente a
livello internazionale non contavamo
niente anche perché scusate io dico
sempre perché nella speranza che
qualcosa accada un ente che si chiama
istituto zooprofilattico cambiamo nome
quando dico dove lavora il realistico
zooprofilattico l'istituto zoo
profilattico e che fate preservativi per
gli elefanti non proprio però vabbè al
di là di questo io farò una battaglia
per cambiare nome
eravamo un gruppetto di ragazzi
volenterosi e abbiamo però nel 1999 in
veneto e in lombardia si è verificata la
più grande e devastante epidemia di
influenza aviaria che si fosse mai
verificata al mondo io mi sono trovata a
dover gestire questa epidemia con
grandissima fatica e con impegno miei
mio e dei miei collaboratori ma abbiamo
capito che questa era una malattia sulla
quale bisognava investire abbiamo capito
che era essenziale sviluppare nuove
tecnologie abbiamo sviluppato il primo
sistema di vaccinazione al mondo per
questa malattia e questo sistema è oggi
incluso nella legislazione europea
questa è stata la prima tigre da questo
il gruppo di sei sette persone è
diventato un gruppo di 70 persone leader
a livello internazionale riconosciuto da
organismi come la fao come
l'organizzazione mondiale della sanità
animale
la commissione europea e siamo riusciti
a tirare tantissimi i finanziamenti in
cinque anni abbiamo attirato 12 milioni
di euro per fare ricerca sapete quanti
ragazzi si pagano con 12 milioni di euro
il mio gruppo a una quarantina di
ragazzi che lavorano precari ma sono
precari che si fanno un curriculum che
imparano a lavorare nell'ambito di un
progetto europeo e sono diventati i loro
stessi leader nel loro nel loro ambito
tant'è che vanno a parlare in america i
miei ragazzi vanno e vengono invitati a
parlare in america il secondo dogma di
cui voglio parlare è che imita noi siamo
in italia ai confini dell'impero no cioè
l'italia non conta niente e quindi
cambiare il miglior ci credo nella
sanità pubblica e ci credo veramente in
quello che faccio e quando ci credi così
devi avere una missione e devi riuscire
anche a cambiare le cose che magari non
sono giuste non ci sono un sacco di cose
che non sono giuste che succedono
e allora ti viene detto non è possibile
cambiare i meccanismi di politica
sanitaria internazionale a acqua italy è
certo difficile perché insomma un conto
è se sei al city si di atlanta o se sei
al pasteur di parigi un conto è se
lavori all'istituto zooprofilattico a
legnaro padova italy però anche qui non
è vero non è vero è la storia del mio
gruppo lo lo lo testimonia
vi ricorderete l'influenza aviaria del
2003 2004
questo virus h5n1 era un virus che
preoccupava moltissimo la comunità
scientifica perché perché il virus
dell'influenza aviaria è il virus più
aggressivo che vi è nel regno animale
il virus dell'influenza aviaria se vuoi
fosse tutti i pennuti tutti pennuti
tutti se il virus dell'influenza aviaria
entrasse qua dentro vi ucciderebbe tutti
capito guardate che i virus di solito
non fanno così perché un virus che
uccide tutti non è tanto intelligente
perché poi che fa disoccupato quindi
quindi è un virus con una virulenza una
cattiveria
estrema beh questo virus dell'influenza
aviaria h5n1 a un certo punto ho fatto
la bella pensata di cominciare infettare
le persone e di uccidere il 50 per cento
delle persone da che infettava e quindi
scusate ma se voi fosse un virologo vi
preoccupereste con una diffusione di
questa epidemia a livello planetario
fidatevi c'era da preoccuparsi e quindi
insomma c'era tutto il sistema sanitario
che si occupa a livello internazionale
di queste patologie in allerta
bene questo virus a un certo punto dall
asia dal vietnam dalla thailandia dalla
cina attraversa l'asia centrale e arriva
in europa è arrivato anche qua da noi
arriva in europa però noi qua siamo
organizzati ci abbiamo i servizi
veterinari subiamo gli istituti
zooprofilattici ci abbiamo la polizia
l'esercito ci abbiamo i soldi per per
risolvere i problemi
bene arriva in africa che la è un po
diversa la situazione perché non ci
hanno mancano gli occhi per piangere
quindi questo virus che uccide il 100
per cento dei pennuti intanto ha steso
quanti tantissimi pennuti e le
popolazioni più povere non ci avevano
più pannuti da mangiare al punto numero
uno secondo c'era il rischio che il
virus del genere infettando delle
persone nelle quali vi è una diciamo
estesa positività per il virus hiv che
un virus immunodepressiva voi capite che
si profilava veramente una catastrofe
insomma mi chiamarono perché noi nel
frattempo eravamo dentro questi progetti
europei mi chiamarono da da uno di
questi laboratori da un laboratorio
nigeriano e mi dissero possiamo mandarti
il virus abbiamo il primo virus africano
vorremmo che voi lo caratterizza ste
e quindi il nostro laboratorio è stato
il primo a caratterizzare a srotolare a
guardare il genoma di questo virus h5n1
nigeriano che tutto il mondo voleva
conoscere perché non si sapeva come
fosse arrivato come si spostava quanto
fosse virulento beh una volta visto il
virus
mi chiamo
uno degli ms e mi disse senti ilaria se
tu ci dai
l'impronta digitale del virus la
sequenza noi lo mettiamo in un database
ad accesso limitato
e poi ci diamo alla password alcun
questo database sarà un accesso a una
quindicina di laboratori su quelli più
importanti
così anche tu magari diventi più
importante io
secondo voi cosa gli ho detto
ma scusate ma a voi vi pare una cosa
logica siamo di fronte a una potenziale
pandemia che potrebbe stendere il 50 per
cento dell'umanità
va bene allora io lavoro con i soldi
vostri con i soldi del contribuente
europeo
l'istituto zooprofilattico un ente
pubblico allora secondo voi io la mia
sequenza la mia ricetta il mio tesoretto
lo metto in un database ad accesso
limitato al quale possano avere accesso
solo 15 laboratori di fatto escludendo a
migliaia e migliaia e migliaia di
ricercatori di poterci lavorare ma al di
là di questo di fatto andando contro
quelli che sono gli interessi della
sanità pubblica
bene io ho detto di no gli ho detto di
no e mi sono messo però in un pasticcio
in un pasticcio gigantesco ovviamente no
perché quelli là quindi ci si arrabbia t
e ovviamente è venuto science da noi che
non è che avviene tanto spesso sono
andata a finire sul wall street giorno
ceduto due pagine sui giornali
eppure che notaste guarda qua che mi
sembro buda che no ma vi pare a voi uno
fa tanto l'italiano così può trendy così
carina lei guarda che toccava in giro
tutto il mondo ha detto questo ci ha le
orecchie così
vabbè new york times match ha appreso e
ha sostenuto questa campagna e per chi
non sa niente squad entro io ci ho avuto
ip pura da m c rsquo ilaria cavo che
andrà sul mio epitaffio però al di là di
questo al di là di questo è partito un
dibattito internazionale su questa
faccenda è oggi
cose sono cambiate sono cambiate perché
varie organizzazioni la faccio tanto
lunga ma in particolare la ms che era
quella che non aveva detto mettilo nel
nostro database ad accesso limitato nel
ci ha messo cinque anni perché sono un
po leggerlo mese però alla fine l'hanno
fatto era hanno fatto questo comunicato
stampa
e questo e hanno passato questa
risoluzione che dice una svolta epocale
una svolta epocale noi promuoviamo la
trasparenza dei dati e promuoviamo il
libero accesso le informazioni quando
siamo a rischio di una pandemia
e tutto questo è venuto dai confini
dell'impero legnaro padova italy o io
penso guardate io non sono un genio su
una normale ho fatto una cosa di buon
senso l'ho fatta col cuore l'ho fatta
perché io ci credo in quello che faccio
bene mi hanno messo nei 50 scienziati
migliori del mondo ma vi pare a voi ma
vi pare
sono stata bollata del numero
revolutionary minds che veramente non mi
merito però ragazzi voi che lavorate in
biomedicina voi che vi dedicate alla
scienza
guardate che le cose si possono fare e
il mondo se ne accorge adesso molto
rapidamente perché ciò due minuti e 33
vi parlerò del terzo dogma che proprio
mi sta qua e che è questo il soffitto di
cristallo le donne le donne non riescono
mai a raggiungere le posizioni apicali
allora signore sapete quando vi regalano
due mazzi di rho di fiori che dentro ci
sono tipo cinque o sei rose e l'ho
portato a casa lo mettete nel vaso e la
mattina dopo la rosa come ecco il
talento femminile in italia è così noi
facciamo studiare le nostre ragazze le
nostre figlie vanno all'università fanno
il dottorato sono bravissime e poi dopo
non riescono a sbocciare non riescono a
mostrare a tutto il mondo il loro
talento e non riescono a restituire
all'italia quello che l'italia ha dato
loro quindi le ragazze sono più brave e
vero no a mamma e papà è vero studiano
di più ma che vogliamo fare è così e
così e poi
essere che ottengono titoli migliori
studiano meglio sono più efficaci e poi
si perdono si perdono cosa fa segretaria
cosa fa lavora su internet
lasciamo perdere cosa fa non è possibile
è quello che però voglio dire che mai
siamo in italia il sistema non aiuta
però ragazze
aprite bene le orecchie qua nessuno vi
regala niente a nessuno manco ai maschi
allora però sappiate che l'unica l'unica
l'unico elemento essenziale ed
insostituibile per diventare donne di
successo è la voglia la voglia matta la
voglia di emergere la voglia di fare
delle salite durissime la voglia di
prendere delle sberle che ti rompono
l'osso del collo che le devi prendere
perché scusate qualcuno qui dentro ha
mai preso sberle nella vita
la sberla e si prendono si prendono ti
rimette in piedi e ricominci e quindi
arriveranno le ingiustizie arriveranno
le difficoltà però dovete essere
orgogliose di essere motori del
cambiamento e dovete essere orgogliosi
del vostro lavoro perché solo così noi
potremmo sperare in un'italia migliore
perché l'italia non può fare a meno del
talento femminile perché se sono più
brave noi che facciamo e lasciamo a casa
ma vi pare una cosa intelligente bisogna
che da un lato il sistema le aiuti ma
dall'altro anche le ragazze si aiutino
da sole ed è difficile lo sappiamo che è
difficile perché abbiamo un mondo
interiore che che fatto di essere mamma
di essere sorella di essere figlia però
ragazze tirate fuori le unghie i denti e
fate vedere quello che sapete fare
questa è la mia penultima diapositiva ve
la faccio vedere perché l'economist ha
fatto una graduatoria di persone
influenti nel 2013
io sono questo stesso sbagliate secondo
me io sono questa e non questa lavoro in
un ente pubblico sono un veterinario che
si occupa di ricerca e voglio essere una
testimonianza per tutte voi perché il
limite deve essere il cielo grazie